I'm honored to salute the exceptional
performances given by the five
outstandingly talented women nominated
for Best Actress in a supporting role
three of them three of them are
first-time nominees all of them are
absolutely stunning here are the
nominees Sally Hawkins
blue Jasmine Jennifer Lawrence American
hustle Lupita Nyong'o 12 years a slave
Julia Roberts August Osage County June
Squibb Nebraska and the Oscar goes to
Lupita Nyong'o
thank you to the Academy for this
incredible recognition it doesn't escape
me for one moment that so much joy in my
life is thanks to so much pain in
someone else's and so I want to salute
the spirit of Patsy for her guidance and
for Solomon thank you for telling her
story and your own Steve McQueen you
charge everything you fashion with the
breath of your own spirit thank you so
much for putting me in this position it
has been the joy of my life I'm certain
that the dead are standing about you and
watching and they are grateful and so am
I to tell
thank you for your fearlessness and how
deeply you went into Solomon telling
Solomon's story Michael Fassbender thank
you so much you were my rock Alfre and
Sarah it was a thrill to work with you
Joe Walker the invisible performer in
the editing room Thank You Sean Bobbitt
Khalid AV ad ruther Pattie Norris thank
you thank you thank you I could not be
here without your work I want to thank
my family for your training and the Yale
School of Drama as well for your
training
my friends the Wilsons this one's for
you my my brother junior sitting by my
side thank you so much you're my best
friend and Ben why are the best friend
my chosen family when I look down at
this golden statue may it remind me and
every little child that no matter where
you're from your dreams are valid thank
you
you